si l'on étudie l'historique de la
relation d' emmanuel macron avec les
gilet jaune on s'aperçoit qu'elle débute
avant même la première manifestation
il a que le mouvement avec un bouquet de
ronces écouter sur ce type de mouvement
je suis toujours prudent parce que
s'agrègent beaucoup de choses qui n'ont
rien à voir s'agrègent toutes les formes
de démagogie
s'agrègent il ya beaucoup de gens d'air
qui sont en train de réagir à ce
mouvement
vous savez il ya beaucoup de gens qui
veulent simplement tout bloquer et des
gens qui n'ont pas beaucoup de projets
pour le pays si ce n'est de le mettre à
l'arrêt les premiers macron démission se
font entendre dès le premier acte sur
les ronds-points et dans les
rassemblements urbain
la première réaction du président face
aux manifestations et le mutisme il
faudra attendre dix jours soit après le
deuxième acte la première prise de
parole publique du locataire de l'elysée
ce mouvement a donné lieu à des
manifestations importantes et aussi à
des violences inacceptables
je veux ici dire que je ne confonds pas
ces actes inacceptables
avec les manifestations sur lesquels ils
se sont greffés je ne confonds pas les
casseurs avec des concitoyens qu'ils
veulent faire passer un message cette
distinction sera le fil rouge de tout la
communication de l'exécutif
emmanuel macron tentera de répondre aux
revendications des manifestants mais en
évitant soigneusement de les nommer une
façon de désincarné la colère populaire
il ne prononce pas une seule fois les
mots gilet jaune lors de ces annonces du
10 décembre 2018 ni même lors de ses
voeux du nouvel an au cours desquelles
ils optent pour le coup de semonce que
certains prennent pour prétexte de
parler au nom du peuple et n'étant en
fait que les porte voix d'une foule
haineuse c'est tout simplement la
négation de la france le peuple est
souverain il s'exprime lors des
élections il y choisit des représentants
qui font la loi une vision très
verticale de la démocratie qui s'oppose
à celle défendue par les gilet jaune qui
demandent l'instauration du riq ce
fameux référendum d'initiative citoyenne
est un outil de démocratie directe il
permet aux peuples d'amendé la politique
menée par le gouvernement
en dehors des périodes électorales
la mesure sera écartée par emmanuel
macron à l'issue du grand débat national
le président tient en sus au printemps
2010 9 des propos polémiques concernant
la gestion des manifestations
moi j'aime pas le terme de répression
parce qu'il ne correspond pas à la
réalité ne parlez pas de répression de
violences policières ces mots sont
inacceptables dans un état de droit et
pourtant le bilan de ce mouvement fait
bien état de nombreux blessés graves la
plupart du fait de tir de l bd ou de
grenades lacrymogènes ou de
désencerclement selon les sources entre
14 et 30 manifestants ont été épargnés
et parmi eux jérôme rodriguez l'une des
figures du mouvement sans oublier la
mort de zineb redouane à la suite d'un
tir de grenade lacrymogène par un
policier pourtant aucune sanction
administrative n'a été prise par le
directeur général de la police nationale
et ce contre l'avis de l'igpn des
blessures un décès et le sentiment d'une
impunité policières ont cristallisé les
tensions entre le gouvernement et une
partie de la population on a vu par la
suite des gilets jaunes dans la rue
contre la réforme des retraites du
chômage contre la loi sécurité globale
ou le pass sanitaires nul ne sait
combien de temps encore cette
contestation durera mais elle est déjà
inscrite dans ce morceau d'histoire de
la vème république adolphe thiers avait
sa commune de gaulle ses soixante
huitard emmanuel macron aura vu la vie
en jaune